but today after more than a hundred
years of production the free-flowing
crude here is long gone while plenty of
heavy or thick oil remains Chevron needs
to pump hot steam into the ground to
thin the oil this field is 20 to 25
square miles
anywhere from 300 feet to 1,600 feet
deep that's an enormous amount of rock
that has to be heated so that this oil
will flow at rates that allow us to
produce a commercial enterprise it takes
81 trillion BTUs of energy every day
just to warm the ground here at Kern
enough energy to power one large air
conditioner for every human being on the
planet in Alaska BP hopes that a similar
technique will help save Prudhoe Bay
they're building giant heaters to warm
and soften heavy oil which is otherwise
too thick to recover warming oil in the
Arctic is no easy trick but BP hopes it
will keep Prudhoe producing for years to
come
the difficulty of extracting oil from
old fields around the world makes n wire
an appealing target over the past
century oil exploration has touched
nearly every corner of the globe
there's not a lot easier left to be
found otherwise we would have found it
and that's what we would be targeting
you know right now we're pushing out to
more remote areas we're pushing out to
deeper water whether it's Gulf of Mexico
or even offshore Alaska and continually
looking for larger accumulations in the
Gulf of Mexico they produce twice as
much oil as on Alaska's North Slope and
there's little close to shore that
remains untapped so companies are going
further than ever before
a discover deep seas discover deep seas
as Chevron 0 Charlie Victor Bay please
go ahead nearly a hundred miles offshore
this ship is drilling one of the deepest
holes ever drilled in the Gulf of Mexico
Chevron is drilling down more than five
miles as deep as Mount Everest is tall
all to look for oil that might be hidden
in seven million year old rocks